[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul aka the guy whose wife
says Size Doesn't Matter in this video
we're breaking down the Ant-Man and the
WASP quantumania trailer the first
official look at the film has just
released online and throughout this
video we're going to be going through
the tiny details in it Easter eggs new
characters and also what we think will
be happening in the film some of this
was shown at both the 23 and Comic-Con
and we will be going over the info from
that as well to bring you the best
picture on what's going to be in the
film if you enjoy the video please hit
the thumbs up button and don't forget to
subscribe to hang around for all our
breakdowns and Easter egg videos but out
of the way a huge thank you for clicking
this now let's get into the trailer
and give you more time
if you help me
so
What's it gonna be
Batman Okay so the first thing we have
to talk about is Kang the Conqueror
played by Jonathan major as he's gonna
be the new big bad in the MCU and it's
even possible that Scott doesn't survive
the encounter with him this brings to
fruition the warning that was given to
us by he who remains at the end of Loki
season 1. he explained Nathaniel
Richard's backstory and how killing him
would free the Multiverse invariance but
that it would also have a downside to it
the Multiverse being opened would Usher
forth his variants too and eventually
this will lead to a multiversal war we
know Kang Dynasty and Secret Wars are on
the horizon and this movie will very
much be setting the stage for those
films now the variants can be either
good or bad but the latter leads to some
of the most evil villains in the entire
Multiverse Kang recently had his origin
story redone in the phenomenal graphic
novel Kang the Conqueror only myself
left to conquer in that a young
Nathaniel Richards traveled back in time
to explore the past due the feature
basically being at a standstill
everything was a Utopia because of how
far humanity and Technology had come and
those people didn't really Advance their
progress so he traveled back and it's
here that he encountered a future
version of himself in Kang I don't want
to go too in depth on it as this video
has a lot of ground to cover but it
basically was about Nathaniel trying to
stop himself turning into his older
version and in doing so he ended up
becoming him he would then watch as he
come across himself as a boy and it
created a loop in which he was
constantly pushing as young Asaf down a
path of conquering Jonathan Majors is
bringing a lot to the role and when
discussing it with variety he said that
this will be a warrior version of Kang
the one shown at d23 had a much more
extended scene of what we got in the
Online release and it had Kang asking
him to steal something this comes off
the back of the What's it gonna be line
that we hear at the end now going up the
leaks we have a fair idea of what this
is gonna be according to them Kang will
be after a chair that allows him to
travel through the Multiverse now in the
comics he did have a Time chair that
allowed him to travel through time but
the MCU will switch up the way it
operates we know from the d23 trailer
that he's holding Cassie hostage and
Scott will have to potentially get this
chair in order to get her back as he
remains said Kang is a conqueror who
will stop at nothing to take over the
Multiverse therefore getting this chair
will allow him to hop from one dimension
to the next in order to take over that
realm you've already seen remnants of
this and in Loki we saw a version of
Avengers Tower which had King on it it's
a bit of a moral quandary a bit of a
quandary Mania if you will because Scott
could potentially Doom trillions of
lives across infinite realities just to
save his daughter now Kang will be
located in the quantum realm and it
seems like Janet has already had
experience with this we'll talk about
what this could be later on but it looks
like they're bringing things full circle
from Ant-Man in the wasp in that when we
traveled in the quantum realm we could
see what appeared to be Kang's City and
I believe this is where we'll be
venturing in the movie Kang comes across
as a cold-blooded [ __ ] and in
the d23 trailer he actually asks Scott
if he'd killed him before it was one of
the best lines in the league and sadly
it doesn't make it to this but I'm here
to tell you that's what he says and it's
really really badass he shakes his scene
in a Jonathan major way and the costume
looks so close to the source material in
that his suit helped him to travel
through time and it also came with a
blue face mask that covered his head I
actually think in this that they might
be sort of pulling from the way the
quantum masks looked in endgame and just
in the same way they had a blue visor
pop over them this could be used on the
helmet too a huge allows to our sponsors
bloodline Heroes of lithis in case you
don't know bloodline Heroes of lithis is
a hero collector fantasy RPG that allows
you to build your kingdom whilst you
collect Champions to defend it whereas
most games have straightforward
characters bloodline lets you create
your own Legendary Champions by
combining the Bloodlines of elves demons
demigods Orcs dwarves lichens Dragonborn
and more if you've not tried out
bloodline now is the best time to do so
because the game just got the biggest
update ever with a newly added
mind-blowing hybrid system you can
customize your Champions through their
unique marriage system to create over
800 different new hybrids between any
two Bloodlines this brings across a
number of things including their unique
appearance abilities and also their
talents it's free to play on both
Android and iOS and we've got a QR code
on screen right now that you just need
to scan to get the game just in time for
Halloween they also have a new vampire
Clan called the accursed which brings a
brand new lineage to Bloodline they are
the darkest and most terrifying
assassins yet to be found in the world
of lithis an undead clan that Rose
alongside the dark elves From the Ashes
of their Homeland cataclysm they can not
only nuke your enemy but also sustain
themselves on the battlefield during
longer fights by participating in the
Halloween event starting October 27th
you will be able to obtain a cursed
Champion for free on the seventh day as
I said the game is also completely free
to play in a packs with a visually
stunning 3D realistic Graphics
interesting storylines and a journey
that lets you build your own kingdom
economy and also bloodline all you have
to do is either scan the QR code on
screen right now or use my link in the
description if you do this you'll get a
free special starter pack worth twenty
dollars that has 10 energy potions one
hundred thousand gold and 100 diamonds
in it don't forget you get a free
vampire champion this Halloween starting
the 27th of October I hope to see you in
the game now let's get into the rest of
the video now it looks like Kang is
working alongside some of the characters
in who Bill Murray is playing though it
wasn't shown here we know the d23
version had modak in it who's absent
from this first look he is apparently
going to be played by Darren cross who
you'll no doubt know from the first
Ant-Man movie originally yellow jacket
he was taken out by being shrunk and
sent to the quantum realm similar to how
the character appears in the comics his
body proportions are all over the place
and this is likely due to the breakdown
that the suit had in the movie looks
like he's almost cybernetic here with
the mask being a big change up on the
comics in which he was basically just a
big head with arms and legs I think the
design is pretty solid but I am hoping
that we get one more in line with the
comics eventually his suit could end up
coming apart and if the mask detaches
then it might leave him looking closer
to what he does in the source material
now originally in the comics modak was a
character called George tolerton but
looks like they changed things up yet
and honestly I think this works better
with this story we don't really need a
big origin for the character if he
simply cross and it gets us up to speed
with him instantly now I have some
theories about how stuff is gonna go
down in the movie just to have a sort of
narrative thing with it so obviously we
know Kang isn't gonna lose in the film
because the two upcoming Avengers movies
are centered around him so he's probably
gonna win but and it's a big but well a
little butt Scott can't just take
nothing but elves in this movie
therefore I think he's gonna get a win
against Murdoch who is the side villain
and then he'll get beat against Kang so
it's like well well at least he got one
win in anyway As for Bill Murray we know
that he's gonna be playing krylar who
too is a character from the comics he's
only had one appearance that I can think
of and this was in The Incredible Hulk
issue 156 this had him living in the
microverse which my Marvel don't
actually own the rights to use so I
think they've changed this up to the
quantum realm and that he'll be working
for Kang the extended look in the d23
trailer showed us that he clearly knew
Janet and there was a bit of chemistry
there with Hank even be like whoa what
the hell I think that Janet probably
lived down there for a long time and
then she saw the evil Deeds that Kang
was doing and tried to escape Captain
Obvious there but yeah that's just what
I'm guessing looking at this very small
split-second look this explains why she
doesn't want to go into the quantum
realm because she knows what danger is
waiting for her now Cassie is gonna be a
big character in the film and this is
the first time we'll see her donning her
own suit in the comics she had many
aliases including the name stature but
at the moment she's going on this
Stinger I'm guessing that we'll just be
skipping over the statue thing and
likely just sticking with stinger we get
a couple of looks at his suit in the
teaser and this contains the purple
color scheme that the character is known
for they might also go with some of her
other nicknames like and girl and so on
but yeah that's what I think she'll be
known as the comics had her stealing
Hank's pimtech and making a suit herself
but here it looks like she's working
alongside the group in order to save the
world look at that t-shirt only a person
saving the world would wear that a skirt
seemed to just be a celebrity at this
point who's more focused on his ego
Cassie on the other hand is actually
putting things into action and trying to
do the right thing you know from the d23
teaser that he's gonna get a call from
her whilst she's in prison and that he's
gonna have to go in in order to bail her
out Scott was of course in prison the
first Ant-Man movie because he was
trying to do the right thing too and he
sees this very much echoed in his
daughter however he thinks she's wasting
her life when in reality she's actually
doing something that matters kinda have
a feeling that he might try take her
under his wing and this could be what
ends up getting her in trouble this will
mean it's more crushing for him when she
gets put in danger Because deep down
he'll know that he put her there after
the loss of Janet Hank didn't want to
put hope in the WASP costume because he
feared that she could end up being put
into perilous situations and think this
is very much the same thing with got now
her introduction also pushes us further
towards a Young Avengers movie so far
the MCU has slowly being slotting
characters and a place for this to
happen and we've had a number of them
popping up in the Disney Plus shows I'd
actually love to see something where the
Avengers get defeated in Kang Dynasty
and then we have a gap where groups like
The Thunderbolts and Young Avengers have
to fill in something similar actually
happened in the new 52 and when the
Justice League were beaten Lex Luthor
pulled together a group in the interim
in the graphic novel forever evil I
think this would be the best way to do
it and hopefully we get something along
those lines anyway she ends up pulling
them into the quantum realm after
accidentally activating the device that
sends them down here this is described
as a sort of satellite that sends a
signal down to the realm and it's clear
that this is what pulls them in here she
meets strange looking creatures and an
almost tribe like gang that don't really
seem to be part of Kang's forces in the
d23 trailer we had a quick flash of a
woman rocking some awesome God of War
face paint mixed with a bit of hellblade
I'm not share who this is but judging by
the armor she may be part of this group
the graphic novel we talked about
earlier actually had multiple versions
of ravona rensslayer so maybe it's her
that's a big reach I just thought I'd
let you know I'm in the graphic novel
can constantly kept trying to get her to
love him but no matter what happened it
either led to her death or her complete
rejection there were many versions of
her that all are completely different
and if you ask me just based on this
half a second shot I'm guessing it's her
again we are Chumps at the channel and I
want to turn this over to you guys to
see if you know who this is and if you
do then drop it below thanks there's
also another one in robes and this looks
slightly like Acro yeah it might be him
but I'm not 100 sure there's lots of
different civilizations down there
Beyond just kangs and we might see Wars
breaking out amongst the quantum Realm
I used to ask myself a lot of questions
Scott you're at ex-con
how are you an Avenger that doesn't make
sense
but everywhere I go people tell me the
same thing thank you Spiderman
now I've done this trailer breakdown in
a weird order because I just wanted to
talk about Kang up top and then go over
the new characters and editions because
of this we've kind of skipped over the
main character in the movie Scott though
it sounds like I'm not interested in
what's going on with him I think that
he's actually gonna get one of the most
interesting arcs that he's ever gone on
I think this film is gonna be totally
different from the Ant-Man movies that
have come before and we might see him
going on a journey that humbles him out
at this point we now know that he's
pretty much a celebrity in the MCU and
this has been shown across a number of
things Ms Marvel showed us that he'd
been on a podcast titled big me little
me and we know this filled in a lot of
details of what happened in Avengers end
game for the general public this is how
characters in Multiverse of Madness knew
about the snap and so on and so forth
here we catch him walking through the
street smiling like he's Toby Maguire
after just getting Venom Powers he
returns to Baskin and Robbins where he's
named the employee of the century he was
of course fired in the first movie
because Baskins and Robins they always
find out they always find out now here
we get a better look at his new suit
which now has a circle in the center of
it he high-fives the kid at a bench and
you can see that he has an Ant-Man
backpack he also gets called Spider-Man
and sadly though we know who Ant-Man is
we still don't know who's behind that
mask now in the d23 trailer we also had
an extra shot of him reading a book
titled lookout for the little guy I
think this entire movie is going to be
filled with terrible puns like my videos
and also about humbling him out his ego
has got too big eh and now he's gonna be
taking down a Pega too I think at this
point he might even be the most famous
Avenger in the MCU and this is why Kang
taking him out is gonna be big news at
the heart of it this movie also seems
like it's very much gonna be a one about
a father and daughter who just aren't
connecting Scott got lost to the quantum
realm for five years and that's time
that he missed out with Cassie instead
of spending his time with her now though
he's so wrapped up in himself that it's
just pushed the pair apart I think this
movie will very much be about him
examining what's actually important to
him and losing Cassie will push him down
a path of going back to the old ageless
guy that we know and love now the cool
little details are that we see them
riding on the back of one of the
creatures in the quantum realm he's sort
of popped up when a character journeyed
down there and is very much an almost
ocean-like feeling to the entire thing
with him being like stingrays link Kang
also places a device into a similar
machine to what mess up ghost particles
in the last movie chronopolis itself
looks like the inner workings of a clock
and these circular gears all fit
together in really interesting ways you
also see Scott as giant man well he
might not be giant because he's still
very small but he's bigger compared to
everything else there's also a bit where
we see him running alongside himself
getting Reed Richards I'm guessing this
is a variant and as we know from d23
Kang asks whether he's killed Scott
before this could be a flashback to Kang
actually showing how he's killed others
and if we look in the bottom there are
several antmen this might be a flash of
the multiversal war that broke out with
them all dying at Kang's hands also
Goodbye Yellow Brick row by Elton John
plays throughout and this of course is
tied to the Wizard of Oz and basically
saying goodbye to reality such a great
song to have in the background and it
keeps up the tempo come on Goodbye
Yellow Brick Road come on
where
are we
the secret Universe beneath ours
what are you so afraid of
there's something I never told you and
that wraps up the trailer and all the
things I think you probably want to know
about the movie as with my thoughts I'm
getting really hyped and I think this is
going to be a great way to start phase
five phase four has kind of had its ups
and downs I think it's very much just
been about recovering from the snap and
also focused on laying the groundwork
for the next phase it's kind of this
interim whereas this trailer is showing
us what we can expect next think
Jonathan Majors really stole the show in
Loki and it looks like he's gonna be
doing the same thing here it's gonna be
a big entrance for Kang if he actually
manages to take Scott out and this will
set the stage for him being a [ __ ]
around and find out billing personally I
love the town for this and with him
being introduced in an Ant-Man movie I
was worried that it would be goofy and
just all over the place I think when it
comes to jokes that the MCU can miss so
I'm glad they've just kept things
sincere with the characters and are
playing it straight lots of things like
this I get me really excited for what's
to come and I'd obviously love to hear
your thoughts on the teaser below we are
in competition right now and giving away
three copies of top a Maverick on the
15th of November and all you have to do
to be on the chance of winning is like
the video make sure you subscribe the
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the trailer
you make the comments at random on the
15th and the winners of the last one are
on screen right now save that to you
then message me on Twitter at heavy
spoilers Beyond something else to watch
make sure you check out our breakdown of
Black Adam which will be linked on
screen right now we've gone over the
whole thing from top to bottom lots of
things to talk about including that very
big post credit scene so head over there
right after this by the way thanks for
sticking through the video I've been
poor I'll see you next time take care
peace